hey guys so this is a very quick video
to tell you that there is no video this
week somewhat paradoxically um basically
I have my final exam in theoretical
physics in about 30 hours time and I
need to revise for that so I hope your
understanding in me not uploading a
video as normal normal service actually
normal service is never going to be
received because next week I'll be doing
at least a couple of videos about what
I've been up to in Oxford when there
hasn't been any work to do so ain't
thinking like the week hopefully I'll
actually go to show you some fun stuff I
realize the past couple of weeks have
been fun for either of us for the one
viewer alright but I do want to take
this opportunity to say thank you
because I've I've had some really lovely
comments from you guys and some messages
that you sent me saying thank you for
these videos saying there are motivating
to you that they've made you want to do
well and go to uni and stuff like that
and I really love getting these comments
it makes my day whenever I get one of
those and I want you guys to know that
in watching these videos and leaving me
these these comments and send me
messages you've really motivated me my
motivation levels took a bit of a dip
this year and you guys come into my
videos has really helped me and I've
realized that it would be unfair for me
to say to you guys kearney gotta do your
best the school that we should get to
come here and have all this fun you know
I'm expecting the best of you you guys
should expect the best of me I should do
my best as well so you guys have really
motivated me to do that and I can only
say thank you and I had to see if there
any of my friends who are watching this
and any friends who are watching this in
the future I want to say thank you guys
because I wouldn't have made it this far
without you I really wouldn't especially
this year I've I really owe you guys
several drinks anyway I really should go
because I'm a person who's but sit there
are professors on Oxford and my maths
teacher didn't think I should have taken
a little further maths well how am I in
this situation again it's all a bit
weird I don't know I mean it's all a bit
weird says the man talking to a camera
in his purge stream the morning before
one of the most important examples of
his life makes sense anyway I will see
you guys soon
sorry for the crappy upload but this'll
have to do for this week the next time
you see me I will be a free man and I
will not have my exam did actually
comment on whether you like the exam did
I don't keep it for the you know gratify
wait until I can grow a decent exam bit
god this this has been an odd one hasn't
it
thanks for sticking around if you if you
are still watching this part anyway I
need to go I will see you guys next week
I will see you on the other side fest I
don't who's taking exams this week